Hello everybody, welcome to another
tango technique class at home. I hope
you're all doing fine.
In today's class we will see a few
exercises that are useful for the man
inside a giro.
As you know, in a giro the woman does a
molinete around the man, yeah? She does
front, side, back, side, front, side,
back and so on, yeah? And usually the
man walks forward, always forward using
pivots so that the walk is a circle,
like this, yeah? Front, pivot, front,
front, front, yeah?
Now, there are many things that the man
can do to spice up this walk. He can,
for example, use
uh changes of weight in half time to use
the same leg twice. He can do these
changes of weight in different ways, in
zero position, crossing back. He can
also use lots of adornments in between
steps, like little boleo's back,
punteo's, lapices, crosses front.
So, in today's class, after the warm up,
we will do together a selection of
exercises that work the technique for
several of these elements that you can
put in your giro.
And um these will be very useful for
later when you want to create nice
combinations of walk inside a giro,
okay?
So, let's start with a warm up. Okay,
warm up. So, we always put our feet
together first and we use a few seconds
to find our center, relax, breathe and
let the weight of our body just settle
and come down, okay? And then we start
with shoulder rotations, yeah? Remember
make a big circle and don't bend the
elbows when you move the shoulders. Just
keep the arms relaxed to the sides.
Let's do it eight times.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
and 8. Now we do arm circles like this,
yeah? You go front, you go up. Don't
bend the elbows here. Make sure your
elbows are straight and your shoulders
down, yeah? And then open to the sides
and put the hands a little behind the
back so that you
stretch the chest muscles, okay? And
then down, yeah? We do it eight times.
and 8. That is really improving your
embrace a lot and your your posture in
the upper body.
Then we stretch the side of our torso.
This will also improve your posture,
yeah? We raise one arm and then with the
hand that is down, we slide it down the
leg until you can touch your knee, the
side of your knee, yeah? Or if you can,
a little more. And then we keep this
stretch for a few seconds and then we
use the hand that is up to pull
ourselves back vertical and then we drop
the arm and we repeat with the other
arm, okay? So we do it four times each
side.
Go down.
Hold it.
And up.
And 1
Go down.
Hold it.
And up.
Slide the hand down.
Hold the stretch.
And go up.
And 2
Slide down the leg.
Hold the stretch.
And up.
Three,
go down.
Hold the stretch.
And up.
And three, go down.
Hold the stretch.
And up.
And the last one, four.
Go down. Hold the stretch.
And up.
And four.
Go down. Hold the stretch.
And up. Okay, now we open the legs a
little bit.
Make sure that your feet are pointing
forward. Yeah?
And we bend the knees slightly. This
will help us block the hip because in
this exercise, the hip and the head have
to look forward all the time. And we
make a circle with the arms in front of
us, below the chest. Yeah? And we rotate
the torso left and right like this.
Without moving the hips and without
moving the head. Okay? We do it 16
times. Very relaxed and try to find the
limit of your rotation. Okay?
And one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight. Eight more. One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay, now we stretch the knees. We grab
our hips and then we bend forward until
our back is parallel with the floor.
Yeah, like this.
And then we keep going down. Yeah, using
the weight of our head. We let it hang
here, very relaxed.
And then we bounce three times. Bounce,
bounce, bounce. And then slowly
we go up again. Okay?
This will stretch the lower part of our
back and the back of our legs. Yeah,
which is good, for example, for walking.
Yeah, it gives you a more elastic and
relaxed step.
Okay, so let's do it eight times. And go
down. One.
Bounce, bounce, bounce.
And up.
Two.
Bounce, bounce, bounce.
And up.
Three.
Bounce, bounce, bounce.
Up.
Four.
Bounce, bounce, bounce.
Up.
Five.
Bounce, bounce, bounce.
Up.
Six.
Bounce, bounce, bounce.
Up.
Seven.
Bounce, bounce, bounce.
Up. And the last one, eight.
And up. And now we're going to relax our
hips. So we go back back with the hip
and then we move the hip to the side.
Now make sure that your knees are
straight and the heels are on the floor.
Yeah, you should feel a light stretch on
the inside of the leg. That is diagonal.
Okay? And then we go forward. Then we go
to the other side. Now you feel the
stretch here.
And then back. So we complete a whole
circle. We do eight circles in one
direction and then eight circles in the
other direction. And during the whole
time you keep the head on the same
position. Yeah, don't move the head.
Okay, let's go.
One.
Two.
Three.
four
five, make a big circle, yeah? Six.
Seven.
And eight.
Yeah? As big as you can. Okay, other
direction. One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
And eight.
Okay. And the last exercise, very
important because
it strengthens our lower leg and the
ankle, which are very important for your
balance, yeah? And you know, in tango,
balance is very important. So, if you
want, you can keep your hands on the
hips, and then you bend the knees, and
you relax the knees, and you bounce
three times. One, two, three. Then you
stretch the knees.
You go a little bit forward with your
torso, so the weight of the body is
almost on the toes, and then you go up,
yeah? Basically, you push the floor down
with the toes, so that the floor pushes
you up. And then you hold this position
for a few seconds, three seconds, and
then you go down slowly, controlled,
yeah? Don't drop like this, cuz it's not
good. Go down controlled, okay? Let's do
it three times.
Bounce, bounce, bounce. One, go up.
Hold it.
And down.
Bounce, bounce, bounce. Two.
Go up. Hold it.
And down.
Three.
Bounce, bounce, bounce. Go up. Hold it.
And down. Four. bounce, bounce, bounce.
Up.
Hold it.
And down. Five, bounce, bounce, bounce.
Go up, hold it, keep your core tight,
yeah?
And down. Six, bounce, bounce, bounce.
Go up.
Hold it.
And down. Seven, bounce, bounce, bounce.
Go up.
Hold it.
And down. And eight, bounce, bounce,
bounce.
Go up.
Hold it a few seconds.
And go down slowly, okay? So, that was
the warm up, and now we are ready to go
to the first exercise. Okay, in this
first exercise, we will imagine that we
are starting a giro from an ocho forward
with a pasada of the woman. So, my first
position is like this. The weight is on
the right foot, and the left foot is in
front of me, and the leg is stretched,
yeah? Your standing leg is bent,
and your free leg is straight.
Now, imagine, yeah, the woman is doing
an ocho front and a pasada over my foot,
and she's stepping towards my right
side.
So, after this position, the next
movement that I do is I change weight
from my right foot to the left foot,
yeah? At the same time, I follow the
woman, I turn the torso to the right,
and I do a 180° pivot over my left foot,
like this. Boom. And then I change
weight to the right,
I go down again, and I prepare the next
pasada. That's the exercise, yeah?
The structure is like this. Pasada
position,
change weight, pivot, change weight,
pasada.
Pasada, change weight to the left foot,
pivot on the left foot, change to the
right foot, and pasada again. Now, one
detail is that when you start the
exercise, your
your level is quite low because your
standing leg is bent.
But, when you do the pivot
here,
your standing leg is straight, so you
should go up. Yeah? You're up here, and
then when you finish the pivot and you
change the weight to the right foot, you
bend the right leg and you go low again.
Yeah? So, you start low,
you go up when you do the pivot,
you change weight, you go down again,
and on the pasada you are low again.
Okay?
So, we will do this uh
eight times going to the right, and then
we will switch legs. We will do it eight
more times going to the left. And then
we will repeat again everything, but
faster. Now, we will start with a slow
speed. So, I will follow my metronome.
It's always 58 bpm, two beats per bar,
like this. Yeah?
And
the rhythm,
how we use the rhythm in the exercise is
very very slow. So, one beat is for the
transfer of weight and the pivot. Yeah?
Pivot, change, pasada. And
pivot, change, pasada. So, very slow so
you can work properly on making your
movement very clean and very precise.
Okay? So, I'll put this here.
And we do it eight times
together. Yeah? So, weight on the right
foot, bend the leg, left foot in front
of you,
and let's do it eight times.
And
one
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
Okay? If you want at home later, you can
do it with music, any way you want,
yeah? I'm using the metronome because it
forces me to be very precise. If my
movements are off off the beat, with the
metronome it's very very easy to hear,
yeah?
Okay, so now let's flip it
and
let's do it to the left. So, my weight
now is on the left foot, yeah? The left
leg is bent, the right leg is stretched
in front, and the pivot will be
towards your left, okay? So, let's do it
eight times together.
Get ready.
And
one
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
Okay?
Good.
So, now
we will to it in half time, so
I will
put um
extra subdivision
in the rhythm.
Yeah?
Because it will help me to hear if I am
precise when I do it in half time, like
this.
One um um, yeah? That's the speed.
Step, pivot, pasada.
Okay? And because um
it's faster now, we will do it 16 times
to each side. Yeah?
Between each repetition, I will uh leave
two beats of wait time so that we can
prepare for the next repetition.
Otherwise, you will get dizzy. Yeah?
So, let's do it now
to the left uh sorry, to the right 16
times. So, weight on the right foot,
bend the standing leg, left foot in
front,
and let's do it together.
One.
Weight.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Eight more.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay. Good. Now, let's do it to the
left.
So, weight on the
left foot, yeah? Knee bent, low, and
right foot in front for the pass side,
yeah? Let's do it 16 times now turning
to the left.
And
one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Eight more.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay. Great.
So, let's go to the next exercise. Okay,
in this exercise, we are already inside
the hero, and the woman is doing her
side step and back step around the man,
yeah? Side and back. So, when the woman
does the side-step, the man usually
walks forward inside her side-step. And
when she goes back, he does a front-step
following her back-step. Yeah? So, this
will be the exercise, two steps front.
But, we will add something special. The
two steps front of the man are done with
the same leg.
That means that you need a change of
weight in half time
between both steps. So, the exercise
looks like this. You start in zero
position with the Now, let's imagine
that the hero is going to the right.
Yeah, like before. So, I start with my
weight on the left foot and I do a step
front with the right. Yeah? This step is
the step that goes on her side-step. So,
when you do it, you have to turn the
torso to the right at the same time.
Because you are coming after the woman.
Yeah, the woman is always ahead of you.
So, with the torso you anticipate her
step. Yeah? This is the first movement.
But, all
and you see
I am low. Yeah, my knees are bent on the
whole exercise I do it low. Now, you do
a 180° pivot and then you change weight
in zero position and you do a second
step forward. This step forward of the
man is the step that goes with her
back-step. Now, she's going back and you
are just following her back leg. Okay?
That's the exercise. So, to finish you
do a final pivot and a change of weight
so that you have again the same start.
Yeah? So, I show you once again. Weight
on the left, bend the knee.
Step front with right, turn the torso to
the right.
Pivot and change weight.
Front with right.
Pivot and change weight. Okay, very
simple but very useful.
So, um
one very important thing
be sure that
first you do the pivot completely and
then you change weight, yeah? Don't do
the change of weight before the pivot
because it looks so bad that I don't
even want to show you how it looks like,
yeah? It's horrible. So, finish the
pivot and then change weight, yeah? And
also be careful that your feet always
move on the floor caressing the floor.
Don't lift
the feet. Not in this exercise. We will
lift the foot but later, yeah? For this
exercise your feet need to move
on the floor
all the time, yeah?
Especially the back foot now when you
collect
the feet on the floor, okay?
So, let's do it with a metronome.
58 bpm like before.
And we will do it slowly, yeah? It will
be
step pivot change, step pivot change.
Okay? So, eight times to the right. Get
ready, zero position, weight on the
left.
And we step forward with right, okay?
And
one change, one change weight.
Two
and
two.
Three
and
three.
Four and
four.
Five
and five.
Six and six.
Seven
and seven.
Eight
and
eight.
Okay?
Good. Now, we will do the same but
to the left. Yeah?
So, now the weight is on the right
leg to begin. I bend the knee
and then I start with the left foot
going to the left. Okay? So, let's do it
slowly.
Pay attention to the technique and
making everything very clean, very exact
eight times. Okay? Let's go.
And
one and
one.
Two
and
two.
Three
and
three.
Four and
four.
Five
and five.
Six and six.
Seven and seven.
Eight and eight.
Okay? Good. So, now we have to do it
faster
at a speed that would be realistic.
Yeah?
So,
one subdivision on the beat. Yeah,
because now we will use it for the
change of weight between steps front.
And this is
actually the speed that you would use in
a normal dance, in a realistic dance.
Yeah, it would look like this.
And one and one. Yeah? That's the speed.
Yeah? Step and step. So now, it's very
important that you anticipate with the
torso the direction of the woman. This
will really help you
be able to keep up with the speed. Okay?
So let's do it 16 times
to each side. Let's start with the
right. So, zero position, weight on the
left, and we start with the right going
front. Let's do it 16 times.
And
one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Eight more.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay? Good. Now, 16 times to the other
side.
So, I put my weight on the right and I
start with left front, pivot front.
Okay? Let's do it together, 16 times.
Get ready.
And
one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Eight more.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
And
okay?
Great.
If you have problems keeping up with the
speed, if it feels too fast,
the trick for me, really, what helps is
the torsion of the upper body.
Because
um you are already looking in the new
direction, so to do it fast now, you
just need to worry about your hip. Yeah?
If you don't use enough torsion and you
go straight like this, then you have to
turn the whole body and that takes a lot
of work when you have to turn the whole
body. So, if you already solved the
upper body before the pivot,
then you only need to twist the hip and
that takes much less effort. So, you
will be able to do the movement quite
fast without so much effort, okay?
Great. So, let's go to the next
exercise. Okay, in this exercise we are
in the part of the heel where the woman
is doing her back side front steps,
yeah? This is the half time that she
usually does around the man.
Back side front, these three steps. The
man does the following. When the woman
goes back, he does a front step
following her back step, yeah? When she
does her small side step, the man
doesn't do anything. He just keeps
following her movement around him with
the torso, yeah? So, torso.
And when she does her front step, the
man does a big pivot 180° and then ends
with a side step, yeah? When she's in
her front step, okay? I'll show you
again.
So, the woman is doing her back step
around you, so you follow with a front
step. The woman does the side step, you
just keep following her with your torso
and then she does the front step, so you
do a pivot and you end on a side step
when she steps front, okay? So, that's
the exercise. Front pivot side, yeah?
But, we will use an adornment on the
pivot. The man will do a little boleo
back like this, yeah?
Boleo back.
Um it's important that you keep your
knees together when you do the boleo.
Only use your knee. Don't separate your
knees
when you do the boleo because this is
very unsafe in the milonga, and it also
doesn't fit with this movement, yeah? We
will do it like this.
Front step, yeah? With torsion to the
right. Then you do the 180° pivot, and
the inertia from the pivot will help you
lift the leg and end with a side step,
yeah? When you are here, you only need
to transfer your weight completely to
the left leg and do a 90° pivot
to find again the starting position. So,
that's the exercise.
Front step with torsion, because the
woman is going around you, yeah? Then
pivot and a little voleo that ends on a
side step, and then a little 90° pivot,
and then you are again ready to start
the next repetition, okay? So, we will
uh do it
slowly
with a metronome,
yeah?
So, it will be
step, pivot, side, finish, okay? Very
slowly. Let's do it eight times to the
right side. So, you start in zero
position, the weight is on the left
foot, and you go front with right, pivot
with little voleo and side step, okay?
Let's do it eight times together.
And
one,
side,
finish.
Two,
three,
four,
five,
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
And that's it. Yeah? Now let's do it
eight times
to the left. So you start in zero
position
and the weight on the right foot. Yeah?
And one tip is that for the little
boleo, you have to do it as late as you
can. Yeah? So first make sure that you
finish the torsion, yeah? And you start
the pivot
and then you lift the leg as late as you
can. You should be able
to see your back foot before you lift
the leg. Yeah? If you cannot see your
back foot, then it's too early. You need
to rotate more. So make sure that you
rotate completely and then you do the
movement. Okay?
So let's do it eight times to the to the
left.
Get ready.
And let's go.
And
one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
And that's it, okay? Now, we will do it
16 times,
but faster. So, subdivision,
and it will be front pivot side, yeah?
And then wait, front pivot side.
Okay.
Let's go.
So, zero position, weight on the left
foot, and we start with the right, okay?
And
one.
Finish.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Eight more.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
All right, okay? Now, we do it 16 times
to the left. So, zero position, and your
weight is on the right foot and you
start with the left. Yeah? And then
pivot to the left with oleo and side and
finish. Okay?
Fast. Let's do it 16 times together.
And
one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Eight more.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay? Good.
This one is fun. It's very dynamic.
Okay. So, let's go to the next exercise.
Okay. In this exercise, we are in the
part of the hero where the woman is
doing front and side around the man.
Yeah? So,
on her front step, usually the man does
a side step
in the opposite direction of her step.
So, if the woman is stepping front
towards my right side, I am using my
left leg to go to the left against her
direction. This is so that we maintain
the heel, okay? And then, after her
front step, she does a side step around
me. So, after my side step, yeah, front
for the woman, she does her side step, I
do a front step
inside her side step.
So, that would be my movement, side step
and front step. But, as always, to spice
things up, we will use an adornment
between both steps. And the adornment
will be a punteo back. Punteo, yeah? Uh
punteo comes from point in Spanish, and
it means to make a point with your toes
on the floor, like this. And remember
that
when you do a punteo, the accent is not
when the foot goes down, but when the
foot bounces back up, yeah? It's not
like a hammer, boom, because
you can, you know, hurt your your toe or
or chip a nail, but it's when you go up,
boom, accent up, yeah? That's how you do
a punteo.
Now, it's important that you always use
the same line for both steps. So, if you
are doing the side step on this line,
then the punteo
is more or less 90° following the same
line.
And the front step
is also following the same line, yeah?
So, the movement looks like this, side
punteo front, yeah? The punteo actually
helps
to do the side step, yeah?
Then, uh the woman does her side step,
and then she does her back step. But, we
finish the exercise here. We just need
to do a 180° pivot after the front step
and finish in zero position, yeah? So, I
do it again for you.
Side step, punteo, front, 180° pivot,
and then don't change weight because you
need the left leg to start again the
side step. Now,
you might have noticed that because I
use a 180° pivot, now I have a different
line. Now, I'm facing this wall instead
of that one. Yeah? So, that means that
the on each repetition, we will be
facing
a different wall. Now, I have to do it
on this direction. Side, punteo, front,
180. Now, I'm facing this wall. Side,
punteo, front, 180. Now, I'm facing that
wall. Okay? So, this adds more interest
to the exercise. Yeah? The change of
front makes it a little more
interesting. And also, it's more
realistic because in the heel of the
woman, you wouldn't use a pivot bigger
than 180° to follow her heel. Okay?
Good. So,
let's do it
um this time when we do it slowly, we
will do it 16 times. Yeah? Because we
don't need to wait so much between
repetitions. So, we have time to do it a
little more. Okay?
So, I will use the
slow version of the beat. Yeah? 1 2 1 2
And the speed will be very slow. It will
be like this. Look.
And
side, punteo, front, pivot. Side,
punteo, front, pivot. Okay? Yeah? So, I
will start the first one from the back.
But because I'm changing front, you will
be able to see the exercise from every
direction. Okay? So, let's do it 16
times slowly.
Get ready.
Zero position and weight on the right
foot to start with the left
uh
with the side step. Okay, let's go.
And
one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Eight more. One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
And yeah?
If you didn't mess the archings up, you
should always uh and every four
repetitions looking at the same wall.
Yeah? Okay? So, now we will do it 16
times slowly, but
to the other direction. So, instead of
going left now, now we will go right.
And the punteo will be with the left
leg, and then we will step like this,
and then we will do a 180° spin. Yeah?
So, side step to the right.
Punteo, front step with left, 180° 180°
pivot. Okay? Let's do it together 16
times slowly.
Weight on the left and let's start with
the right.
And
one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Eight more.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay?
Good.
Now we will do the same, also 16 times.
Uh but faster. So,
I will
put an extra subdivision here on the
beat
because we will use this extra
subdivision for the punteo, yeah? The
speed is now like this.
And side punteo, front
And pause. Side contao, front pivot.
Wait. Side contao, front pivot.
Wait. Yeah? So, we have a bit of time
between repetitions to find our axis and
prepare the next one. Okay? So, let's do
it
um
16 times
and we will start
with the heel towards the right. So, I
will start with a side step to the left.
Yeah? Contao, front, and then a 180°
pivot.
Okay? Let's do it together. Weight on
the right foot, side step to the left.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Eight more.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay? Good. Now, 16 times
but
with the heel to the left. So, I will go
against the woman. I will start with a
side step to the right. Yeah? She does
front, side. So, I will side, and tail,
front, and 180° turn.
Okay? It's clear, yeah? The structure is
clear. Okay.
So, let's do 16 times together.
Weight on the left.
And
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
Eight more.
One
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
Okay.
Good.
Great. Okay, so we can go now to the
last exercise. Okay, in this last
exercise, the man will do an alternate
version of what we did before in the
previous exercise. So, the woman is
doing exactly the same thing around us.
Yeah? She's doing front and side. Yeah?
Front step and side step around the man.
So, when she does her front step, like
before, I do a side step. Yeah, and I go
against her direction. So, if her front
step is going towards my right side, I
do a side step towards the left so that
we maintain the heel. Yeah? And then,
after her front step, she's doing her
side step around me. So, like before, I
will step front inside her side step.
But, the special thing in this
exercise will be that I want to use the
same leg twice.
The left leg will do the side step, and
the left leg will also do the front
step. So, to do that, obviously, I need
a change of weight in between to be able
to use the same leg twice. So, the idea
will be very similar to the punteo we
did before. After the side step, instead
of doing the punteo,
like we did before,
I will do a close back like this. Yeah?
And I will put my weight on this foot so
that I can now go front with my left leg
again. Yeah? So, the exercise is side
step on this line, following this line,
then cross back 90 degrees. Yeah?
Following the same line, and then front
step inside the side step of the woman,
following the same line.
And then, like we did before, to finish
the exercise, I will use a 180 degrees
pivot and a change of weight so that I
can do again the side step with the
left. And now, like before, I change my
front. Yeah? Because I use a 180 degrees
pivot. So, now I'm looking in this way.
Yeah? I show you again.
Side, close back,
front, 180 degrees pivot, change weight,
Side, close, back,
step front in the same line, 180° pivot,
change weight. Yeah? Okay? So, we will
do it first slowly, 16 times.
And
I will start with my back to you, yeah?
But because I'm changing front on each
repetition, you will be able to see the
exercise from every direction. And we
will do it slowly, yeah?
It will be
side, close, front, pivot. Side, close,
front, pivot. Very slowly.
So that we can focus on cleanness. Okay?
So, get ready.
Zero position, and the weight is on the
right so that we can start with the
left. Yeah? Remember the hero is going
to the right now. The woman is doing
front, so I do side, and then she's
doing side, so I cross back and I do a
could be a sacada, yeah? Okay.
Let's do Let's go. 16 times.
And
one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Eight more. One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay.
Now, one technical thing, yeah, is that
when you do the side step, you are on a
normal height. Your Your Your legs are
mostly almost straight, yeah? So, you
are quite high. But, when you do the
cross back, you bend both knees, so you
go low, yeah? And then when you do the
front step, you go higher than for the
pivot, yeah? So, you are up
up on the side step,
low on the cross,
and then
up on the front step and on the pivot,
okay? So, now let's do it with slowly 16
times to the other side. So, remember
the heel is now going to the left, yeah?
The woman is doing front and side to the
left. So, I go side step to the right.
And then I cross back, and then I go
front, and then 90° pivot, okay? Let's
do it.
Weight on the left, yeah?
And
one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay? Great. So, now we're going to do
it 16 times
fast. So,
one extra repetition.
And we will do side, cross, front,
pivot. Yeah?
We will have a little pause between
repetitions so that we have time to find
our balance and prepare the next one.
Okay? So, zero position, the heel is
going to the right. Yeah? Front, side.
So, I start with a side step to the
left. Okay? Let's do it 16 times.
And
one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay?
Now we do it 16 times
with the heel going to the left. So, the
woman is going forward and side to my
left. So, I start with a side step to my
right, cross on front, 180° pivot. Okay?
Let's do it 16 times fast.
And
one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Eight more.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay.
So, we are finished.
That was the last one.
If you practice
all these different possibilities
quite a lot, yeah, then you will be able
to mix and match them when you do a
giro. This we will see in another video,
yeah, examples of how to put all these
exercises together in complete
sequences. And
the advantage of practicing the
technique separately like this in little
blocks is that it will make you very
precise with your giros. Your giros will
look very clean and very precise with
the rhythm of the music, yeah. It's
always a good idea to break things down
in little parts and practice those parts
in isolation a lot. And then when you
put it all back together, it all looks
cleaner because you have worked on the
details of each part, rather than if you
keep practicing long sequences over and
over and over, okay? This brings more
results. Okay, thanks a lot for
watching. I hope you are practicing and
you are improving. I hope you are all
doing fine in this difficult time. And I
look forward to see you in the next
video. Bye-bye.